bonjour
les suisses vous voulez vous suicider
non non pas du tout pourquoi moi parce
que je vous voilà hésité à aller et
venir et puis parce qu'on a quand même
le meilleur spot pour ça ici alors
écoutez moi je veux pas m'immiscer dans
votre vie privée je suis sûr que vous
avez toutes les meilleures raisons de la
terre pour en finir mais moi en tant que
professionnel je suis obligé de vous
prévenir un drone la falaise comme ça
attaque on arrive ici ici on saute on
est venu pour ça
sauf que en cas de vent retour en
arrière on rebondit ici aïe
et là on atterrit en bas et on a plus qu
à gémir en attendant les secours
abrités ça c'est pour vous
en fait je suis quelqu'un qui me jugent
à bas il faudra le dire à votre visage
alors parce que là on peut pas deviner
[ __ ] de garçons 4 pc de ma grand mère
carte postale je suis aveugle ça existe
encore ce truc là
c'est génial c'est bien quand même bien
dormir puisque je voulais pas trop en
parler mais j'ai vu des trucs sur
internet mon gars c'est horrible en fait
ils enlèvent dévier sa famille a plus de
limites l'envoyé doute ta carte paris
gare saint-lazare aux petits airs il
faut que tu mènes l'anc est assez cool
on dirait un peu un épisode de 24 heures
chrono mais en plus vieux et en plus
loin
c'est à l'envers qui dispose elle a
disparu
comment c'est possible que ce soit parti
comme ça oui surveiller pas mais c'est
une prison ici messieurs non mais
attendez un pas se montre alors
effectivement on a reçu un appel de la
maison de retraite
mais bon c'est la première fois en c'est
une vraie passoire le bas mais du coup
concrètement vous pouvez faire quoi à
concrètement on peut pas lancer un avis
de recherche est la télé ils passent
leur temps avec leur alerte enlèvement
on va faire pareil où les convenances l'
alerte enlèvement pour votre première
question est ce que votre mère est
majeur peter pan ab je m'énerve pas je
m'énerve pas du tout le monde
je fais simplement mon travail on va
tous nous ici on est plus jeune je son
fils tu as déjà vu ça toi un ram
entendez vous me tutoyez la wii ou
tutoie reste mon va tout va bien tout va
bien tout va bien